今日のお昼はー
やばい、全然覚えてねぇ
何食ったっけ？
今日確か遊戯王の大会に
行っててー
めちゃくちゃ急いでて
サンドイッチを食べたような
気が、します。
ちなみに大会は
4勝1敗でした。
クンデミーナ無限連結
ハードな3D食感グミ
好きな味を無限連結
カンデミーナっていうグミ皆さんしってますか？
なんかすごい
食感の硬いカンデミーナっていう
グミがあるんですけども
なんかそれのパクリ……
パクリではないな
それのパクリではないんですけどー
クンデミーナという
あの、
カンデミーナって「噛む」
クンデミーナは
この組み立てるの「組む」
っていう意味で
無限連結クンデミーナというグミがありました。
早速開けて見たところではあるんですけども、
なんかね、無限連結ってかいてあるわけですよ
「無限」非常に重い言葉です。
あぁー
なんかすごい形がすごいなんか
プラモのパーツみたいな
見た目ですね。
これなんか
連結できるらしいんですよ
好きな味を
無限連結ということは…？
これ、これ
たくさん買えば
無限に連結できるんじゃね？
というわけで
今回クンデミーナを100個買ってみましたー！
と言いたいところなんですけども
なんかすごい人気なのか
知んないんですけど
近くのコンビニどこ探してもなくて
非常に悔しいながらも
4つしか買えませんでした。
なんか可愛いね、オレ
4つならば4つで仕方ねぇ
4つ分で限界の高さまで連結させて
超巨大なグミを作ろうと思います。
ではいこう
はい、では連結させていきましょう。
なんか食べ物で遊ぶと
食べ物で遊ぶなってよく言われるんですけども
もう、自らあそびにいってますからねw
こ、これどうやって連結させるんだろう？
まず連結の仕方がわかんないんだよなぁ
こう？
こうか、こうだねぇ
連結成功しました！
多分こういう感じでどんどん連結させていけば
いいんだと思います。
これ本当に大丈夫か？
連結部分が甘くてすごく不安になりそうなんですけど
まあやってみましょう。
うわぁ、なんかしょうもねえな
これすげぇしょうもないんですけど
無限にグミが繋がるって
そうそうないものだと
思うんで
結構画期的だと思うんすよね
実用性はないですけど
わぁすごい！×3
ちゃんと繋がってる。
これちょっと4袋でバカにしましたけど
結構な長さになりそうですよ
はい
というわけで
1袋繋げました。
いやすごい！×3
あっ、
はい、というわけですごいっすねぇ
あの、一袋だけでも
このサイズ感までなることがわかりました。
結構これ長いっすよ。だって
ちがうちがうあちゃっ
はい、あーあぢゃ
ちょっとさきが不安になりましたが
できる限り僕の持っている
クンデミーナ分で連結させていければいいなと思っております。
では！
よし、いくぜぇ
というわけで、できましたが
長さ的にはでもまぁ
1メートル（？）
ぐらいは全然ある
1メートルぐらいですね。
多分1メートルぐらい、1メートルこえてるねぇ！
1メートル20センチくらいの長さにはなってるんじゃないかな
と思います。
ただこれねぇ、作ってみて思ったんですけども
1袋繋げた瞬間思ったのが
弱い
非常に弱いんで
これ多分
ちょっとこれ空中に浮かすと
すぐ壊れちゃうんですよね
空中分解しちゃうんですよ。
ちょっ輪っかにしちゃおう
これ輪っかにしてもね持ち上げるとすぐバラバラってなるのが
もう目に見えてるんですよ
あれ？意外と…いける！？
あーあぢゃ。
しってたよ。
ちょっと強度を高めますか！
ハンマーで叩けば間違いなく強度は増すので
しっかりくっつけお前ら！
はっ食いしばれ！
ドンッ！
あ゛ぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
その後私はクンデミーナの研究をし続け
ついに5000メートルを超えるクンデミーナの開発に成功。
そのクンデミーナは大気圏を突破し火星に到達。
こうして人類はクンデミーナをつかって
火星で生活するようになった。